depuis toujours l'histoire raconte la
geste sanglante des héros qui ont
conquis le monde mais d'autres
personnages touchés par la lumière d'une
pensée supérieur ont éclairé ce monde de
leur savoir c'est le cas de foucque si
l'auteur du plus ancien traité sur les
sciences humaines
le i ching déclaré patrimoine de
l'humanité
un jour moi fut xi jeu 20 sur cette
terre fasciné par le spectacle qui
s'offrait à mes yeux je montais sur le
plus haut sommet d'une montagne
je regardais en l'air pour observer les
phénomènes du ciel givi une immensité
sans début et sans fin un nombre
incroyable des toiles toutes rondes
comme des billes se déplaçait lentement
sans jamais s'arrêter
tandis que la lune et le soleil se
succédaient à intervalles réguliers
comprendre le ciel n'est pas difficile
une penseuse je peux en calcul et les
mouvements je regardais en bas et
observer les phénomènes de la terre je
vis que le chaud et le froid
tout comme la tempête et le calme se
succédaient eux aussi à intervalles
réguliers
comprendre la terre n'est pas difficile
passage je peux en calcul et les
mutations je regardait droit devant moi
et observé l'homme et la femme
il vivait dans la confusion bouleversé
par les difficultés qui arrivaient sans
préavis sur leur vie ils agissaient
inconsidérément sans jamais progresser
comprendre la vie humaine n'est pas
difficile pensais je peux calculer ces
changements je massy pour méditer je
sortis de moi-même et rentrer en
communication avec tout ce qui existe
je compris alors que la vie la terre et
le ciel sont liés par une même loi et
que l'univers est composée par des
parcelles autonome et intelligente en
nombre infini
quand certaines de ces parcelles
décident de s'unir entre elles elles
créent des corps définis tels qu'une
étoile un arbre ou un homme toutefois
chacun en son temps ces corps se
détériore inexorablement leur parcelle
les kits alors et se répandent dans
l'univers où elles formeront d'autres
corps avec d'autres parcelles
quand les parcelles créer un être vivant
elle vibre dans continue du corps et man
alors des sons des odeurs des couleurs
et d'autres signaux qui dans leur
ensemble rangs de ce corps unique dans
la création
quand l'être vivant se déplacent qu'il
soit un homme un animal ou une graine
il marque son passage par une traînée
indélébile de ses propres signaux ainsi
toute chose est identifiable dans la
création de sa naissance à sa
disparition par les traces qu'elle
laisse
à cet instant la surface de la terre m'a
paru comme une énorme pelote composé
d'une infinité de cordelettes invisible
dont chacune détient une information
c'est par ces signaux que les animaux
perçoivent le danger les pistes à suivre
et des présences même hors de leur vue
l'homme
s'étant séparé du royaume animal a perdu
ses facultés
il ne sait plus saisir le langage de la
nature
cependant son port continue d'émettre
des signaux en imprégnant même les
vêtements qu'ils portent et les choses
qui me touche habituellement puisque il
s'habille et utilise des objets jeu mais
veillez éclairé par une forte conviction
mois foxy je rendrai à l'homme et à la
femme
cette perception qu'ils ont perdu
j'invente ray décimaux visible ainsi ils
sortiront de la confusion
j'ai allumé un feu mis à cuire des
aliments et fut vite entouré par tous
les hommes et les femmes de la terre
lorsqu'il sûr manger suffisamment je
leur demandais de me raconter leur vie
et c'est avec beaucoup de patience que
je les écoutais tous à la fin de mon
enquête
j'en déduis zik l'existence humaine est
une succession aléatoire de période de
changement d'une durée d'environ 20
l'une chacune ces périodes appartiennent
à trente deux typologies de situation
dont chacune est accompagné par son
propre contraire ce qui fait un total de
64 changement
saisir leur arrivée tout comme connaître
leurs fonctions aurait permis aux hommes
et aux femmes de prévenir les dangers et
de mieux gérer leur vie
c'est alors qu'une ligne blanche m'a
paru à l'horizon soudas elle se casse à
en deux puis redevint une seule ligne
qui de nouveau ce cas ça en deux et ce à
l'infini
c'étaient les signaux que je cherchais
je prie un cailloux pointus et sur le
rocher
je traçais un trait je l'appelais ciel
au dessous je traçais un trait cassé en
deux je l'appelais terre je ne perdez
pas de vue la ligne blanche elle
s'étirait jusqu'à se casser en deux puis
immédiatement après se contractait pour
redevenir une seule lit ces signaux sont
doubles mescla meije ils ont la capacité
de rester eux-mêmes aussi bien que de se
transformer en leur contraire
je redouble et les trains que j'avais
dessiné sur le rocher sous le trait du
ciel j'ajoute et un trait au milieu
duquel je traçais un petit cercle
figurant un mouvement vers l'extérieur
sous le trait cassés de la terre
j'ajoute et un autre très casse et au
milieu duquel je traçais une petite
croix figurant un mouvement vers
l'intérieur
la ligne était toujours là elle pulse
est comme un corps humain
alors j'ai ajouté un trait et attraits
cassé en deux entre les traits déjà
tracé et les appeler hommes puisque
l'homme vit entre la terre et le ciel
j'avais donc citerai un hexagram
connectant entre eux le ciel la terre et
l'homme c'était mon premier signal
visible je l'observé changer l'un des
traits songerait tout le dessin qui
deviendrait un autre hexagram ces
combinaisons ne peuvent pas être infinie
pensais-je je combine est alors un trait
et un trait cassé dans tous les examens
possibles et il y en avait 64 autant que
les périodes de changement que j'avais
calculé mois foxy j'avais déchiffrer le
langage de la création ou signaux
invisible de la nature je pouvais
maintenant ajouté mais 64 signaux bien
visible un parent changement
après un long travail d'enquêté je
réussis à accoupler chaque hexagram aux
changements qui lui correspondait et je
leur donner un nom
il ne restait plus qu'à comprendre quand
ces changements surviendrait alors j'ai
inventé l'oracle jeu prises un caillou
rond
sur lequel je grave et d'un côté un
trait pour le oui du côté opposé
je grave est un trek assez pour le nom
sur une autre phase du caillou je grave
est le trait au cercle pour le oui qui
se change en on est du côté opposé
je grave est le trait à la croix pour le
nom qui se change en oui le caillou lui
contenait la réponse à mes cogitations
si je lançais à terre quand il aurait
fini de rouler sa phase visible
exposerait l'un des quatre traits ainsi
si je lançais six fois je tiendrai un
hexagram et si je comparais c'est
hexagram ou 64 déjà classé j'aurais son
nom et ses caractéristiques
selon mes calculs cède hexagram devait
représenter la période que je vivais à
ce moment précis et ce qu'il allait
advenir de mon futur proche
c'était un moment important je gardais
longtemps le caillou dans mes mains pour
l'imprégner de mai signaux de maison de
mes vibrations jusqu'à ce qu'il soit
perçu comme étant moi même à l'égard de
la création je suis tourner lentement le
caillou dans mes mains mon silence puis
je le lance est à terre quand il eut
terminé de rouler il afficha le trait
plein
je grave et attraits plein sur une paroi
de la roche je repris le caillou le fit
tourner et le relancer
quand il eut terminé de rouler il
afficha le trait cassé avec la croix
impliquant un changement je grave est un
trait cassé avec la croix au dessus du
trait plein jeu reprit le caillou et le
lancer quatre fois encore j'obtins deux
traits pleins un trait cassé et un trait
plein que je grave et les uns au-dessus
des autres
cette hexagram était celui de la période
que je traversais en ce moment quand je
lui comparé aux hexagram place et je fus
ravi de voir qu'il s'agissait du feu une
période durant laquelle le ciel est
favorable à l'homme illuminant son
oeuvre jusqu'au 4 régions du monde
je me sentais récompensés cependant mon
hexagram prévoyait un changement le
deuxième trait était cassée avec une
croix et donc il devenait plein cela
change elles hexagram du feu en un autre
qui représentait mon avenir
il s'agissait de la possession une
période de sublimes réussite
je remercie le ciel pour autant de
bienveillance et je considérais ma
mission comme achevé
moi aussi
j'ai rendu service à l'humanité de par
mon code binaire
j'ai communiqué avec la création dans
mon livre des changements le etching
appelé le livre vivant pour ses
intuitions étonnante
j'ai répertorié toutes les périodes
possibles de la vie humaine par mon
oracle conformément aux lois de la
nature
j'ai donné aux hommes et aux femmes la
méthode la plus efficace pour saisir les
signaux de l'avenir ainsi personne ne
pourra dire je ne m'y attendais pas